Background they come here tough. Ok. Well. It's not that they're doing. The john guy. Will be. You double click.
Are you. Ve r a s d e c k. Yeah. But. Fifty. And for the last ten years.
I've been deeply involved in developing a new model for the occupancy of. Will lead. You to a village called.
The include. Which we're very happy to call the solar unit. And the name is peter berg.
Been in a triad twenty years now. Cocky aquarian spirit in california.
We find it through furder study and enjoyment into pacific and. Got here around fourteen years ago and help.
Create live in a combine click here will get you to. The. Nearly nine hundred acres and with thirty five k. Northwest.
A business. Bill and cliffs. Is a privately owned strata title village. On nine hundred eighty.
Thirty five northwest of lism all of its physical shape is three. Descending. Values. Of about three hundred acres.
He these represent. Three main parts of the village. You have the north end which is very very secluded.
And alive with wildlife.
You have to send a valley where most of the activity goes on
and we have the south end which is a very highly developed and. Organic the.
It's within these three that liza lay within another sort of value so. From wherever you are situated.
The eclipse is a magnificent view of the actual cliff and dylan. We live in a valley that is bounded on one side.
By a flat topped cliff. Ever the timbered. Had on the other side.
Rolling out in the lane and he too we have mccullough rages are getting steeper and he's good and. Oh.
Yeah the village would have around. Eighty different homes or structures. Of make maybe.
Seventy would be occupied and turned in fifteen locks. And all the certainly in setting it up.
Took up a balance between the requirements of nature of human requirements and economic requirements
and we made a formula. Thirty thirty thirty huge you'd have a third of the property is under private control.
For your own gardens and home. About a third of it is controlled with your name. It works for you for affection or.
For some economic activity like. Orchard and the third is set aside as a wildlife area.
Specifically to get created back in the quality that can go. Yellow.
This is where we differ from most other communities. There is no. Philosophical or religious or political.
Kind of ties here this was a village that was designed by a visionary guy from nimbin terry mcgee.
It was put together by. The legal side of things were put together by. Tony to got a little more so this time.
And it was put together as a multiple occupancy based on the draft of the malta talk you can see the did come out a few
years before all and that allowed. A certain portion of the land to be our and.
Individually with and the rest held in common. And will. Will come back to this later on. However that.
The way it was put together. And the very word god.
We had experienced an awful lot of trouble with council settling it it seemed to be the state government saying yes you
can do things like this.
And the council saying well you can do it
but not really in our backyard it out back out even though that given the development. Proveable had been given and.
Everything was being done out of that pita talk of wow. What about that side of the problems with council.
That virtually. A classic response. Could be study. There will always be a sign.
We were encouraged in the hills by by state government.
We were trying to be pushed out of the hills by local government
and federal government paid for it all for the whole mess. It's cost the government a lot of money.
And it is at best sickly it's a reflection of a lack of integration on the level of government.
And that is state government saw the need for people to settle in the hills to change.
Clapped out farms into organic paradises to change been employed hughes.
And to people who built their own homes and their own assets. And local government.
Didn't want to do this on one fact but they did it. I assume this. Meant a different look.
When we did receive the approval. The mayor died shortly. In that period. And in between. Day to day.
Final lodging of yep a bureaucracy put a request for a one
and twenty year bridge which was going to cost something like five million dollars. And then said.
No one can move on an established.
Is build and so they put as a muti outside the law we were illegal occupants of the land.
By by design by local council and from there on it went on to parade or a shared raid really. Off. Of needling and.
Plastering that. Beggars description. From having to put every tree on the property onto a map and to what slocum.
Would stand on what size it would be and fire hydrants every two meters.
It was a it was a mad house day maid put twenty five thousand dollars in engineering reports on bits of land that
really need any and when i look back on those days. The only thing i find in. Credible and. Hard to believe.
Is that so many of us stuck it out. Out of the very first twenty people who landed here we still have fifteen of them.
And three of the others come back regularly wishing they hadn't holed up. So it. It did two things for us.
It taught us how to handle bureaucracy. It taught us that sometimes confrontation. Is necessary but.
More than anything else. Well it is together. As a group of people.
Because we all come from different walks of our lives
and peter had come from brisbane i'd come from rocky other people. Many people had never been on the line and.
We were here we. Because we were illegal we couldn't make the rug.
People were travelling up and down hills carrying buckets of water i mean it was quite frightening.
And finally i suppose we.
We started to feel our sin and we started doing a bit of ogling and doing a bit of construction
and we brought things to a head. We've had would be ten years of problems with.
With local government it was only really a couple of the individual within the bureaucracy of the lose more council.
We brought things to such a head at one stage in the guy that threatened to take us into coal. And we said.
Take it with nazi. Because we publicly defying. Him. But we didn't we just told the truth about.
At that time we were called. Feral humans.
And that's the name of court and i know that i work with indigo rocker so yet that kano and then we had a feral humans.
And the whole notion of a fourth level of government. Which we were here.
We want to empower ourselves to make the decisions about our wildlife area about our roads.
And not keep each and every decision old local government. So that whole process was alien to him. D.
Everett bureaucrats thought that was promised it would come in if the bridge to us. It wasn't good and to us.
It always was the essence.
You while you might you must make a new system which both capitalism and communism in it into a new marriage.
Are i myself. I'm a green economist. And i get very upset if i say divide and rule. Ethics that is being done by.
Us which says you're either a commie or you're a capitalist. Rose as a matter of fact we had d.c. Urges ourselves.
When it comes to making a stand on our car our land. You believe.
You have your individual rights you preserved all if you are a capitalist.
When it comes to the point that you need a ride from a neighbor. So when you become a communist you know.
We've got a bit of both. And i can well see from the eyes you did the rock was a debt time. Debt. A group of people.
Settling land. Odd days. A big group. A big group of people yes. Creating a an independent and but only control.
Village was frightening. I must try to. Yeah. I can i can see that.
While they were thinking they're going to be hordes of them. Yeah. You know what i did worry.
We thought we were one of the first of many.
There was real fears of the time that it was going to be a swing in the electorate.
Because all of these new settlers being politically on the other spectrum or something like that infected
and that actually happened.
Deland to release policy of councils today is based on bringing it up to the land to bring stability desirable people
and it's never stated lived it is just a fact of life and it's not corruption that's just how things work.
Yet our western system we point out as you're saying that if your nuclear weapons don't look at each system at their
own. In bill. Let's get on. What it is. Ok we're talking about now i suppose nine hundred eighty two.
We got our proveable in september. Some people moved on straight away.
I didn't actually move on until october eighty three years because i felt the place was falling to pieces.
Nothing was happening. So i came here and started to build my house. And within a month. Three other houses.
Were going up up until that time no one was doing. Council came around and stuck these things on our notice.
On our door stop working mediately and all this bullshit. And in fact i came up here once.
And he stood here for about fifteen minutes and we were all working away and.
No one took the blind bit of notice i and finally called out to me
and he said you've got to stop this work i said yes my friend. When the roof is on.
And we've moved in and it's finished. Our stuff. And he got the same kind of response elsewhere.
It came to a head and they'd agreed deign to do.
What the agreement had always been that we could be a bit of a staged development. We get this. We do that.
We get that. We do that. We had seventeen conditions here. I should explain to them and here you know. Demotivation.
In the minds of the principals.
Was to to create a model that can be used by those millions of unfortunate that are without work or without vision.
We're living in a country. And a system worldwide. That still play first. Pesticides and truck farming.
And it has depopulated to rule population. From.
You know like twenty percent of your farmers to where it is now like of only a few percent. And those people have.
An essence going to the city and. Our pool of unemployed.
And we're trying to reverse that and saying you've got to go into organic farming.
You've got to go into high labor intensity we must start making labor.
Lovely again and gardening is healthy our garden is good for you. So we were always in that mode of mind.
We had to provide something that can be used easily and i think ultimately that's the fight that was on the height.
Behind the scenes is that the establishment.
For whatever reason was not ready to embrace a model that now is so sorely needed.
Because how do you settle people on the land.
It didn't work as a multiple occupancy because the moment to emma was created. The right to withdrawn from it.
You couldn't get a telephone you couldn't get a fourth homeowners grant you were you were a non-citizen.
In fact you could be sprayed on. By the air because you were only one farm. Not five thousand people didn't exist.
Ok we became ruled accidental. We would be well maybe we should just talk a little bit more about that.
And what actually happened.
We've been having all of this trouble
and we had agreed on their stage development they would give us ten building permits for people who were living in bad
conditions here. If we did this. Much of the free.
We did that they gave us a few more did this they gave it so that way that went through.
But as we were coming towards the end of that. One day the planner of the day a guy called peter ryan does.
Send us a letter.
And this supposed to be the eighty four eighty five when the moated block conceicao that actually came out.
And when it came out due to influences from dominant and. They were saying this is all wrong. It shouldn't be.
All the lane should be held in common like you know we can all sit here and. Think about buddha together every night.
So they actually. After up to multiple occupancy cars. And i'm not blaming them.
They just did what they thought was the right thing. But that my.
We got a letter from this planner saying within the terms of the clock you can seek out you are an illegal subdivision
because we had our own internal.
Certificate for our two i was and he said i would suggest you stay your certificates up and forget about the boundary.
So that you just got right up mine a is for a kickoff.
And there was no leadership at that moment one leadership group had collapse over the failure of the development plane
which was to finish the route. If it didn't get finished.
And that development group fell to pieces but some of those people. Popped forward and.
I got involved and we created what we called a legality. And we started with a massive. Letter writing campaign to.
Every bureaucrat and every politician. In federal and state spheres and.
Writing the most heart rending letters about our situation here would put our lives in which we had.
It was all the truth and now after four years. We're told we are an illegal a subdivision.
So it came to a head actually the day before the labor government got kicked out in new south wales one of the last at
bob carr did as environmentalists minister. Was signed a document. Converting this lane.
From rural to rural residential.
And he threw it right back into the lap of the lismore city council said right we've ruled.
We've rezoned a lane that now you issue them with some sort of title. So we ended up with the strata title.
It's not the best way of doing our community and it's been it's been a very very expensive for us. But as i say.
We've had a of.
The strong core group here right from the word go out
and eighty five percent of the people who have come in since then have. Kind of joined that vision.
So we've been extremely lucky we had a few dissenters every community does this everywhere in the world.
But we have very few.
And we've just taken a further step forward now by getting this government money and undertaking certain things. So.
It was destroying that that core group and it was the first four
or five years with all its problems we had to put in i write very early in the piece. Before anything else.
Some neighbors around here and some who live nowhere near here. On public money. Through legal aid.
Took the lismore city to count to call to say that.
This shouldn't be allowed to happen or use a piece of shit in the creek.
Led by a guy who works for the pound
or so security who has very scared of having so security recipients moving next to his farm. Yes.
It went down to the environment of coal land then diamond. Gold and diamond jim was a judge.
And after about three nine months or something he finally got the shits didn't he just said look.
He said bring this case to again tomorrow he said i'm sick of it. But almost everyone agrees.
Yeah it almost killed and nearly killed us. Yeah. Nearly killed us and they did it all on legal aid.
Cost us forty five grain. Eighty the for.
Nine hundred eighty four and i eighty eighty three eighty three eighty three eighty three dollars
and eighty two at the beginning of the year. And now we've got our approval in september.
One final approval in september eighty two this was in january of eighty three.
And this was the first thing we had to encounter. However as i say that the.
About ten people involved at that time to build a group. Yes a little bit wrong girt a caucus.
So the adversity was good. Tells the. Attorney about how i was living.
I've been where i was where i'd come down from rocky. But nothing was happening here. So i had a job. To do in lismore.
And i was living in the northern and i come over every weekend and come up to the board meetings and stuff and.
I could sense. Nothing was happening. And i we knew by then the court case was on i went down as a witness and.
I said to my wife could you stand living in a tent. Bearing in mind that she was fifty three years of age you know.
We bought a maki tent which we still use at bill and cliff's functions and things. That was out there where my car is.
And i our son jason and he friend richard and our daughters ali. Lived in that town. We had hot food.
And we had a fridge in there. He went to school looking clean every day she used to buy.
It with just about got ready to have our roof up. And i had a drunken. Accident. In my motor car.
I told my mother and it was a big beautiful. Toy out a land cruiser i'd always intended to sell it to finish.
The house but it took me about three months or four months. To get the money together to get the repairs done.
So that i could sell it. Yeah it took us ten months.
And in ten months we had this loft up here was ready to move there were no wall. Just the roof on the wall.
We had a big tent under here. And my young daughter had a little tent.
Over here and we used to sleep up in the last name we got that one down and gradually. Well two years.
Basically we had a basic house we just improved a little bit. It's. Our just moving in from.
Exiting executive post in britain and up in a nice apartment
and i really wanted to get away from anything to do with civilization so i walked in buckets for years
and was more interested in sitting in the rain and sitting inside. I'm still building my house after ten years.
Getting there slowly. But you've done a lot of other things out there. I put my total time. That's a difference.
Carry on their world. The thing is to. How could you do it and i do. I think you've got to have a certain.
Philosophical foundation. To do it must either be a grassroots. Worshipper that wants to you know.
Improve nature or have some thoughts compassion to actually do it. And i believe now that. Land should be settled.
Not like i did it. I don't think it is for public consumption i think it's not many people can do it.
In fact that's one of many people are doing it.
Is beautiful and it certainly made me that the country more than i ever could. You know stepping away from that.
Cage of civilization out there amongst the ticks and the mosquitoes and. And the snakes.
But nowadays i favor a mode where you have a little cabin to start with and walk on from there. But. Death work.
Can be accessed by. Less adventurous. Thought. There was a.
There were several different philosophies i think operating at the time. I don't think any of us are really aware.
What all the flush of these were prevalent in people's minds we sort of assumed they were all that the simon they
weren't. There was a very strong group of people who were just want to build a beautiful organic garden.
And avoid people who are into.
Celebrating the low cost of the land and building their own home the home builders and date don't think lifestyle.
The home builders end up with a nice home and. Rudimentary gardens and the garden and have mostly..
Beautiful gardens and. Smaller cabins. There also was a sufficient. Large group of people who were d. If you wish the.
Outcasts. Of a modern society who ran into trouble. Emotionally mentally or financially.
In that big thing called the system and. Came to push for refuge. Very much.
Still a part of our life dollars to act you have compassion for those people.
Nevertheless that creates problems of its own because you have to start thinking for people are dead after what i've
been projecting much a salutation at a mic and part of it.
So one of the things of what's the most important to me i find myself.
Shifting from a very well paid and satisfactory position. In government.
To a non-paid position which a very proud and happy with actually transforming the world in a little way.
In time making a contribution to something. Yeah i think that.
Main battle that we have now in is trying to make authorities reassess the meaning of what.
You see and we have been successful in a couple of minor ways already we. We have made various groups understand.
The already the day to day judge work. If you get paid by. That you know.
There's a lot of work done which people don't get paid but we do a lot of work here voluntarily.
We maintain our roads and all that and.
So yeah that's what we're working on now is trying to get a reassessment of the meaning of what i like to say something
there. At the time that we are starting.
Maybe a year or two after another development tried its way here called mebane springs and they were very orderly.
Very ordered. They were calling for cochran and the corporate plumber.
They were really trying to structure a model society.
Whereas we didn't have no such choice we just took anybody who wanted to come it affect. Memon springs.
Failed because of all the organisation where we succeeded because in the end. I became to be plentiful his village.
John became the trainer for the village. The or the grower can you're going to grow over the village to.
That machine then became the road builder for the village. And strange enough.
In a lot of people who thought they had a skill in one way. In fact coming to live via. Has developed a skill.
It another way we have issues by. Who really wants to be a bad guy but he make shoes and you like beautiful shoes.
And i did it all sorry.
Just i just make a thrift is known and i realized we were different from the other communities in a way.
Is now coming to fruition in a true sense not just legally because of the documentation.
But because we learned to get a so much.
Over this period and found solace from for the strength and we acted like a company more and more.
Finally we could sit down amongst ourselves and saying what the hell is going on. Why are all of a sitting here.
Be basically kept in poverty by the lack of work being available here.
We are positioned in a place here on the one of the gala that we took stock of our skills from society.
And those skills we developed ourselves in the interim. Like mud brick building and let glassing and.
Sense of the cement from the saddam bush walking and building all these things. And we put it together.
And we looked at our place. And we thought look we are living here. On a national park.
Quality bit of land that we ourselves are rehabilitating into the world heritage reserve huish. We've got structure.
To become teachers of this skill. And we've got the skills and we built the teaching around our common skills.
And with that taking stock of a village which i think is unique in astray a battery.
This fourth level government looking at itself and saying what can we do. To solve problems. And here clouds. Are now.
Not getting into the commercial development stage we're talking talk about.
Common growing worked on to do this just that whole which is happening here. In the good alternative.
Of booting programs on right now. By the end of next year we will have completed by the middle of this.
Coming ninety three in one year we will have completed.
Two major buildings i don't know if you saw the one wrapped up in black light. That's going to be the most magnificent.
To building on three levels. And our other building is quite magnificent. And that's all done on voluntary light but.
People do work. You know. Well fur's been a major part of the locals could not a building cleaved sorry. Ok. Without.
We don't i don't consider world. World. So i'm still of the old school i believe that social security.
We have about a third of the people here who have there are in money.
From one source or another about a third of our people are on some sort of pension and.
We have about a third of the people unemployed. That has been the way. This was designed.
This village was designed for income earners. To come here and go down.
And that was based on the fact that they were on the dollar and i could get a grant. And things like. Now.
We've got now where it's about that because we have a hundred fifteen families living in this valley that couldn't
maintain one hundred three hundred cows. Out of those people. The ones that are here now. Virtually becoming.
They're on the verge of wanting to earn a craft something that. One of the reasons why there was so security dependent.